after starting a small account and
turning it into a large one starting to
make thousands of dollars per trade this
is how I would start over with a small
account the strategy I use only takes 60
to 90 minutes in the morning allowing me
or you to go about the rest of your day
not sitting at the charts for hours and
hours just this morning multiple
students of mine made hundreds to
thousands of dollars in the 60 to 90
minutes that they were trading so let's
start from the beginning on how you can
get set up and start your own trading
Journey now I have a 90day beginning
Trader road map that will jump start you
through this journey even more and is a
great supplement for this video you can
download it for free in the description
of this video or using this QR code now
first off let's start with what you
should trade there are so many options
out there it's really confusing when you
first start out there's stocks there's
options there's Forex there's Futures
there's crypto and and they all have
their own different complexities stocks
often require you to have a lot of
capital to actually trade and day trade
options can just be overly complicated
even though they give you really good
leverage for a small account Forex can
give you pretty good leverage too but it
can be a pretty shady place in terms of
brokerages and stuff out there and their
fees can get really high with a small
account and then the other option too is
crypto kind of same thing is you can get
good good leverage but it's also can be
kind of a shady place and the thing I've
really landed on with trading is Futures
I find that it's extremely simple it
doesn't have high potential spread
commissions like Forex does it doesn't
have the complexities that options has
and it's an extremely regulated market
to where pretty much all the Futures
brokerages out there that you will park
your money in are really really safe I
always suggest to still go with the
bigger ones because you know bigger
brokerages are always going to be way
safer to park your money and then just
flat out when it comes down to it I
think they are the best at giving High
leverage being just as simple as trading
stocks literally if you just buy it
where it is and it goes up you make
money and then on the short side as well
if you bet something's going to go down
you get in and then you get out and you
just make money versus you know some of
them with options especially have a lot
of complexities in it that just say
beginning Trader is just not worth the
headache what you want to do is make
trading as simple as possible because
it's going to make all the complexities
smaller and less variables for you to
deal with that'll make it more likely
for to become consistently profitable
quicker so I don't want to dive in too
much about how Futures work but I will
link a video up here that will give you
way more detail about the intricacies
about how Futures work and how you can
trade them if you have no idea what you
want to trade I highly suggest checking
Futures out and that is going to be the
best way for you to grow a small account
now the next thing is how are you going
to start a small account you have really
three options to go through you have a
self-funded account which with Futures
you can probably start with as low as500
up to $11,000 I would say that's a good
sweet spot for how small you can start
or you can go the funded Trader route
and then of course there is the demo
trading route as well so for a funded
trading account there are these websites
and I'll link one down below that I
suggest called Apex Futures but they
will essentially let you pay a monthly
fee and you will go through an
evaluation process of essentially
trading proving that you can become
consistently profitable you know over
generally 7 days I think Apex has but
essentially you just have to prove that
you are consistently profitable at
trading and then from there they will
give you a fully funded account and this
kind of depends on what you sign up for
it can be as low as $225,000
and some can be up to a couple of
hundred thousands of dollars and so if
you want to try and make money quickly
that's probably the best way now the
only caution I have about going the prop
from Trading route is they can be pretty
hefty in fees if you are not able to
pass that funded account Challenge and
then you know consistently make money
doing it because there are monthly fees
to do it there's reset fees there's a
bunch of fees that'll pile on if you're
making mistakes
and not becoming profitable doing it and
so what I highly suggest in the first 30
to 90 days follow that blueprint I
linked down below and demo trade I put a
couple of options in that PDF of where I
suggest to demo trade and what accounts
to set up and what that'll do is it
allows you to you know just figure out
what trading is like get comfortable
reading charts get comfortable actually
trading and what that feels like because
you're going to make a lot of really
silly mistakes in the beginning just
because everyone does and you don't want
to be costing yourself money making
those silly mistakes and so go with the
demo trading route initially you know a
lot of the time you have to pay a data
fee you know that can be $10 to $20 a
month pretty much anywhere you have to
do that and just start out slowly
trading is all about the long game if
you get a really good return you know on
your Investment Portfolio they say have
you know 6 to 7% 10% of return a year
you're doing really well well trading is
is very very similar you want to be
focused on the process and the percent
return so like for example if I make 20%
return on my trading account that is
really good if I could consistently do
that every year and if you're you know
trading a million doll trading account
well that's $200,000 a year that is a
sick full-time income but when you first
start out especially if you go the
funded route you're starting out with
$11,000 20% return is only going to be
$200 it's not really going to seem like
it was worth it for you right you spent
tons of hours every day and all you made
was $200 but again you have to remember
trading is infinitely scalable to some
extent and so if you can be profitable
on a small account you can be profitable
on a big account and so start demo
trading and then if you really want to
push that funded account route then
switch to it down the road and one of
the biggest mistakes a lot of Traders
make in the beginning is thinking win
rate is everything that you know you'll
see even YouTube videos out there that
say oh I have a 90% win rate and you
know you'll think that's really good
because well that sounds really good
right but when it comes down to it it's
about something called your slugging
percentage and essentially what that is
is it's your win rate times your risk
reward ratio and it's essentially
combining those two things and so what
I've realized over time is having a
better risk reward ratio and actually a
lower win rate is easier to be
consistently profitable Trading and so
what I mean by that is if you risk $100
to make $100 that is a one to one risk
War ratio ideally it's better to risk
$100 to make $200 or
$300 that's having a really positive
risk award ratio to where your wins can
make you a lot of money and when you
lose you don't lose that much money
trading can be really stressful and
having it to where you have a let's say
if you lose $300 to only make $100 it
can really wipe out a lot of your gains
easily and losses become even more
stressful and I've done that and it's
just not the way to go it's way better
to feel like okay I don't have to win
very often to still be successful at
this it allows you to switch yourself
into that Traders mindset that
probability mindset and that kind of
Casino mindset that is going to be
consistently profitable in the long run
so the hardest part about trading when
you start out is figuring out
what strategy you were going to trade
with I tried a ton of different ones I
you know jump from strategy to strategy
jump from course to course I tried them
all out and what I eventually landed on
was just taking reversal trades and so
the whole philosophy behind that is that
I felt for me that they made a lot more
sense you know I could visually see when
the market was overextended in One
Direction and when it was more likely to
you know reverse back in the other
direction and I could capitalize on that
and that also allowed me to get a good
risk reward ratio where I'm risking
something like you know $100 when you're
first starting out $50 or then when you
size up you know couple hundred $1,000
and then you you know get three times
that so you know you stick to that
positive risk reward ratio that's really
important for being being consistently
profitable over time and in terms of
Simplicity you know I I tried all these
indicators patterns and what I felt good
at and confident at was just seeing that
okay well where are the you know support
zones and where are the resistance zones
and you know just seeing where those are
and the market is going to bounce off of
those often and the idea is I just make
money on the swings back and forth and
so as a Trader try out a couple
different strategies because you don't
know kind of which style is going to
work for you some people like breakout
trades and continuation trades where
they see a strong Trend and they're able
to continuation trade with that but I
always found that a lot of the times
that just led to me foming you know even
up here maybe it looks like oh this
looks good to keep going to the upside
because we've been in kind of an uptrend
it's kind of gone sideways now it's
going up again I always found like doing
that was a lot easier to get trapped and
just lose money and be on the wrong side
of the market but for visually seeing
you know a lot of the basics and really
just the big picture of what I do is
just see okay well when is the market
just crashed in One Direction either
down or skyrocketed up in the other
direction on the way up and when it does
that the market think of it like a
rubber band The Market will get over
stretched and it will like to snap back
it wants to be in more of an equilibrium
the market likes to be you know in a
more methodical uptrend where it has you
know moves up and pullbacks moves up and
pullbacks that is a healthy Trend where
the Market's more likely to continue
trending but when it does something like
this that's more parabolic it's more
likely to snap back and then for me I
just realized combining that kind of
movement with having a you know a
support Zone and a resistance Zone it
made a lot more likely to be able to
profit and then I was able to you know
have my stop loss in an area where it
made sense and in on the trade and then
look for you know it to move up the rest
of the swing and in this case you know
it did that rubber band effect where it
snapped back to the other side you know
this is my risk here and if you just
kind of visually that looks like I'm
getting three maybe four times a risk on
this trade so I was probably risking
more like 200 250 and this trade was a
really nice swing in that direction and
so I was able to close out and you know
when it comes to trading you don't need
to to go for a massive profit on the
other end all you need to be doing is
capturing you know that middle be part
of the swing and you can consistently
make money doing that really good
Traders only really capture 80% at the
most you know this could be even 40% or
50% of this swing if you count the swing
from all the way down here all the way
up to the highs here and that's totally
okay you can be really really profitable
doing that as long as you have that
really good good risk reward ratio right
and so what I want to do is I want to
walk you through three different trades
over the years of scaling up from a
smaller account to a larger account
you're going to have different steps
along the way at different account sizes
of how you manage your trades how you
enter in and so it's going to be really
crucial for you as a growing Trader to
watch How I trade and enter on each one
of these trade setups we're about to go
through now don't forget to get that
90day Trader road map in the description
of this video it's going to have a ton
of those helpful links that we talked
about but also a ton of stepbystep
helpful information that we just haven't
gone over in this video that you are
really going to want to be paying
attention to as you go through this
process of figuring out your strategy
even if you don't use my strategy but
figuring out your strategy figuring out
how to become consistently profit with
that strategy and just consistently
execute the strategy that is the hardest
part about trading is getting consistent
so let's start out with the first phase
here what you should be doing when you
first start out trading and risking a
small amount in this trade example right
here this is a real trade I've taken on
a small account I'm risking about $100
per trade here and you can risk a lot
less than that I'm trading five
contracts here actually based on this
number five so you could do one5 of that
you could be risking $20 on this trade
so you can start really small and what
you you want to be doing when you first
start out is you want to be just going
for quick easy win you want to keep your
management of your trades as simple as
possible now first off I want to get in
a little bit more of how my strategy
works and how I actually find these
trades now you can see initially I am
betting here that the market is going to
go down and so you can make money
betting the Market's going to go up or
you can bet money that the Market's
going to go down it's really really
simple you know you don't have to do
anything complicated it's called
shorting and it sounds a little
complicated but really at the end of the
day you were just clicking a sell button
instead of a buy button and you're
making money as the market goes down
which is actually in your favor in that
case now the first step to every trade I
take is finding those big picture
resistance or support zones and so for
this particular trade if I go back in
the chart and look is that the market
was coming up to this area and just
looking at the big swings we had touched
up here twice already and so I was I
drew this box now I'm not going to go
over these I'll link a video that dives
way more in depth in how to I how to
draw support and resistance levels and
the five key things I look for but
essentially I said okay I like this area
in the market you know resistance and
support zones can be pretty subjective
you know you could be up here you could
be down here but the idea is if it comes
up anywhere in this area I want to look
for the market to to potentially reverse
right and capture a move down off of
that area and so this is I draw these
levels off of a 15minute chart and then
I enter in my trades on a one or 5
minute chart what this does is drawn on
a bigger picture time frame is it just
allows you to see the bigger picture and
I always found that the higher levels
that the levels from there are just
higher probability because they're on a
bigger time frame versus the smaller
levels there can be a lot more whipsaw
back and forth and so the market right
here that we're looking at is coming up
into this support level here it doesn't
pop up on this chart here because I
think it's slightly out of view just
because it's kind of that big picture
but that's my idea here is first off
we're coming up into that level and then
the second step is well there is this
big move up here and I've drawn an
uptrend line and all I'm looking for is
because when you're counter Trend
trading well you kind of need to
make sure that you know the trend that
you're going against is over right and
so there's a big move right here and I'm
thinking okay I like this to go back
thinking about that rubber band effect
we talked about right it's likely to
come up and if it gives that back up
it's going to snap back and often times
it'll snap back to kind of where it
started and so what I'm looking for here
is I'm looking for it to do that and I
actually have a buy limit down here that
it almost just hit and then is reversed
off of a little bit and so that's all
I'm looking for is is just that quick
move and what you want to do when you
first start out I highly suggest this is
go for a fixed profit Target now I do it
a little more complicated here because I
am more advanced trading on a smaller
account but if we Zoom back to the start
of this trade is all you need to do is
when you enter in a trade is enter in
here and then I like to put my stop loss
where I'm going to get out if the trade
goes against me is in a key area you
know essentially Above This swing here
because I think that hey I think this is
a rubber band effect it's likely to snap
back it'll do that quickly if it does
and if it's just in a strong Trend where
it's just going to bounce and keep going
higher cut your losses right remember
about that risk reward we want to just
risk that $100 lose the $100 if we're
wrong or if we're right you know we
collect $200 or $300 because the worst
thing that you can do as a beginning
Trader and I see people do this is
they'll take their stop loss that sets
at you know at $100 a risk and they'll
say oh let me move it up here a little
bit more or a little bit more give the
trade a little bit more wiggle room and
most of the time the best trades happen
and work out quickly in your favor and
the ones that don't they're just not
going to work out no matter how much
room you give them and so it's better to
just cut your losses and move on and so
once I jump in here that's what I'm
looking for is the market to kind of
give that move back up that's a great
Target and so when you enter into a
trade you want to make sure there's that
rued profit you want to visually see
okay this rubber band can give me about
two times two and a half times my risk
in profit if it goes down to that area
because if it if it doesn't have that
it's not worth the risk there's no good
opportunity there that's your Edge in
the market is making sure that there's
opportunity for you to put that limit
order in an area that makes sense and so
you can see just kind of looking at the
movement of the market it's kind of in
an uptrend right here and so I was
keeping track of well there's this
uptrend here
keep in mind we could come down here and
the bigger overall trend takes control
and we push up from there and so that's
a little more advanced Market reading
there but the idea is you know we have
this small move that I'm looking for the
market to give up and then that Big
Picture level you know hopefully comes
and stacks onto this and pushes it down
even more and so the last thing to jump
in on these trades is I like to see a
Candlestick pattern I like to see some
kind of head and should ERS pattern you
know a a pattern where there's a big
bearish bar here you know a three line
strike pattern essentially or you can
see here as well this Candlestick the
market essentially if you look at what
these do and if you kind of read into
what they're saying the market kind of
came up here in this uptrend and then it
it sold off and then it made a one more
attempt to go higher that's what this
candle is showing it it attempts to go
higher and then it comes back down and
so what that shows me is there is
essentially a micro double top here and
in that trend in terms of giving back
this rubber band effect that's a really
good signal to jump in short here and
bet the Mark's going to go down and so
from there you know just set your limit
order and just leave it now I do suggest
uh when it gets close like this is you
can move your stop loss at least to
break even but generally it's better to
just try and just focus on your entries
what you want to do when you're first
starting out trading is Master the
entries of getting it in manage your
trades will get you a little bit more
money you know let's say increase your
profits by 10% but your entries are
going to be 90% of what makes or breaks
your trading and so learning to just
focus on those and not think about the
management as much because that just
adds again more variables and the more
simpler you can make trading the better
and so just to walk you through kind of
what I did here is all I did was you
know it it almost hit my profit Target
there and I thought hey you know I I see
it in this downtrend here and I'll just
move my stop down and see if I can get a
little bit more in the trade and we'll
talk about some more complex management
steps in the next phase here so you can
know kind of what to do when you get a
little more comfortable reading the
charts and so my trade pretty much got
knocked out here and I think about you
know 180 or something so you know about
two times my risk which was still pretty
much what my target was at and so that's
again a great trade and you just move on
to the next one and so let's jump in
right into phase 2 and our second trade
where I'm actually risking I think $200
to $300 of risk here and then this is
what you want to do once you become a
little more comfortable with trading and
you can see that this is a very very
similar setup in terms of just the
market moves up it comes into a
resistance level that I'm looking for
and I'm just looking for that rubber
band effect to move the market back down
and I found that this is just really
really repetitive and consistent that's
how you make money trading is not
learning 10 different strategies or 10
different patterns to make money off of
it's taking one strategy keeping it
simple and scaling up you can trade $100
with this pattern and easily scale to
$11,000 it's just a number at the end of
the day you know it's going to get a
little more stressful at $11,000 but
that's why you slowly build up to it so
you can get used to that B amount of
money when I first started out trading
you know risking $50 felt crazy and
super intense and now you know at a
blink of an eye I feel like I can put
$500 worth of risk on a trade you just
get used to it and so to walk you
through this trade entry and then how
the management style can change over
time is first off is again always
looking for that larger resistance level
just off of those swings off of a larger
time frame I use a 15-minute I have some
students who use like an hour time frame
to do that and then it's just seen okay
we have a good Trend here but it started
to kind of get overextended right here
you can see with these three you know 5
10 candlesticks that kind of started to
Skyrocket here and then it started to
slow down and so for me I see that as
okay well I see kind of an uptrend here
you know it's kind of getting methodical
but it kind of got overextended and it's
near that area where I'm already
expecting it to reverse and so having
that as a combination
it stacks on top of each other and
increases the likelihood for it to
happen and then from there it's just
looking for that kind of a Candlestick
pattern to show it's starting to reverse
and for me that was well we had a really
big selloff right here these four red
candlesticks shows a lot of selling and
if you look at we hadn't really had that
much kind of selling pressure four
candles in a row for quite a while and
once it's kind of moved up here
especially after this I think that's a
good combination with it coming here and
making two lower highs and that's the
whole thing it's just reading the basics
of okay well a uptrend is made out of
higher highs and higher lows and it when
it's going to shift well it's going to
start making lower lows and lower highs
and so here it makes a higher low and
then a lower low and then here it's
making two lower highs from this peak
that it made and so from there I elect
to jump in short on this bearish
Candlestick right here cuz the market if
you kind of read into these two
candlesticks it it shoots up and then it
shoots lower kind of confirming that
lower high and so for me that's a good
enough confirmation with you know the
support level the uptrend broken and
then those lower Highs coming into play
and then of course looking at the bigger
picture of this kind of rubber band move
up likely to push lower and then from
there I just jump in and to kind of show
you once it kind of moves lower now I've
started to move into more of a fluid
management style the stop here is above
this high right here because I think
that hey this is a swing low I'm
assuming that we're going to start
moving slower off of that and if it
breaks this instead you know and comes
up here and and and makes a higher high
well you know this uptrend is going to
keep going and I just want to cut my
losses right and so from there it starts
to go in my favor and I'm looking at
more okay I'm not looking for two times
fixed profit Target anymore I'm looking
for three fluidly and what I mean by
that is I have a profit Target all the
way down here at about three times my
risk and as it starts to move in my
favor I'm going to move my stop loss
further down and if it really gets going
I'm going to move this further down as
well and I'm just going to slowly move
my stop loss down and my profit Target
down but I'm also going to manage with
how I see the market Market moving and
in this case the market starts making a
really tight downtrend right here and
often I've observed when I see the
market coming up here in a clean
methodical way and then making a really
tight downtrend I want to capture this
move here but as soon as it starts to
you know become a broader downtrend I
don't want to hold through those
pullbacks and swings that the mark could
have because at this point well it could
actually bottom and start an uptrend
right here and so what I decided to do
was essentially manage with this
downtrend line and so that's something
new that I started doing as I became
more comfortable with understanding the
market and being in a trade is I would
be okay to as soon as there was a
Candlestick close or two outside of this
trend line or with the idea of saying
hey if it breaks Above This Candlestick
it's probably breaking above and out of
this trend line I'm going to close out
and get out of the trade and so there I
I closed out for a good profit captured
this you know move down and I think from
there you know looking at this it it
looks like we could have a retracement
up now it could come up here and keep
going lower but again I've captured this
the easy money and the part that is just
good enough for me at that point you
know I don't want to deal with the
choppiness of the market and the fact
that it could just give all those
profits back up I you know am reading
the movement of the market now of course
sometimes it can just have a little
pullback and puke lower and that's a
part of managing your trades so now
let's go into another trade where I'm
actually risking $600 per trade and let
me walk you through the intricacies of
how to scale in and scale out of a trade
this is definitely a lot more
complicated and so I highly suggest
don't do this when you first start out
but it shows you the power of how to do
it this is actually a long example of a
trade we're in that big picture support
Zone we've actually kind of broken out
of it that's okay I like to call those a
failed breakout it's it's just
attempting to fail and break out the
other side but you know I have this
downtrend line in place and then you can
see there's kind of some big moves up
here that shows strength to me and then
we have one more push lower I see this
as a final attempt to go lower and then
right here boom we have a double bottom
this is a nice bullish bar I think at
this point it's essentially confirming a
double bottom here and I think it's
worth jumping in a trade long here
putting my stop loss below here and
getting long and so the first thing
though with that is I didn't feel super
confident right away just because it it
felt like there was a lot of downwards
pressure right here and so I you know
elected to well give it a couple
candlesticks here see okay if it's going
to make one more push lower here boom I
definitely want to get in if that
Candlestick reverses I think that's
showing a lot of strength so I jump in
there but I'm actually not full size
here I'm 2/3 size full size here for
$600 on this particular trade is three
contracts and so what made me more
confident was waiting for this
Candlestick to close out really bullish
that I thought was a strong signal a
strong bullish bar it had you know made
this kind of Little Couple dois here and
then it had made this strong Candlestick
so I put in an order a stop market order
above that essentially getting in Long
at the break of this Candlestick and
then I matched it down with my stops
down here so essentially that made my
total risk to be $600 that's kind of my
full size at the time and so one thing
what you can do is you don't have to
necessarily scale in you can also just
trade smaller size you know let's say uh
full risk is you know $600 and that's
you know three out of three but you can
also just trade oneir size and that's it
you know you could just risk $200 on a
trade because you know you're not as
confident in it the level's not as
strong there's not as much of a you know
flush like this right and so that's what
you can do is when you're not as
confident in spots or if you're just not
feeling on top of your game you can
trade smaller size as well because of
that and so that is two ways to kind of
change how you enter into trades because
that's going to allow you to control and
manage your risk and really good trading
is when you control and manage your risk
when if you're not confident but you
still think it's worth putting a trade
on you do smaller size and when you are
confident that's when you put on larger
size because when it comes to trading no
two trades are the same you know all
these patterns are very similar but
they're not the same at the end of the
day you know the Market's always
different and so over time and by the
time you get to here you're going to
build that intuition into knowing kind
of when you want to put full size on and
when you want to put smaller size on and
so once this kind of broke out to be two
times my risk here I mve to break even
because you know there's no reason to
let it come all the way back here and
turn into a loss right and so what I'm
I'm looking for at this point is I'm
just kind of giving it a mental stop at
this point if the market pulls back all
the way here and just flushes and knocks
me out it'll do that and knock me out at
break even that's always what goes on in
my mind usually when I'm doing this but
it's so unlikely that it happens usually
most likely what will happen is it pulls
back you know and and makes a couple
candlesticks before you know deciding
which way to go and and then then you
can move your stop loss above that and
so that's kind of what I did here just
to kind of skip forward to kind of show
you that is it you know it doesn't look
good it's like okay well maybe it's just
going to give this back up but you can
see it starts to find a bottom here and
I then move my stop loss up and we start
to get some some volatility here there's
a little bit of news that came out and
so that's why I don't like to do a
profit Target in some points because
well it allows you to have these massive
moves where you know I think $1,800 was
three times where I risk and this kind
of move well I'm thinking okay well
we've come back all the way up to here
on the left side here you can see that
we've kind of given back this rubber
band move but it allows you to have the
potential to get massive moves and if
you look at other trades on my channel I
get some massive moves sometimes and so
to just walk you through quickly is I
actually then started to scale out of
this trade and so what I did was the
market had this big Candlestick up it
had a pullback and my observation with
these is hey if it if it's going to hold
this it's going to hold it and so I
would rather scale out of 2/3 my trade
there and you know capture those quick
profits but then also you know I have
this uptrend here I'm watching and so
that's why I left one of these contract
on hey you know maybe it has a little
bit of a snap here knocks me out and
then it takes off and and holds this
uptrend and so that's what I'm kind of
looking for here and it looks pretty
good right here especially since it
barely lock knocked out my my two other
contracts which it's a part of trading
it's going to be frustrating you're
going to have trades where you just
barely get knocked out and then it goes
thousands of dollars of profit in your
way and it just is what it is you don't
want to focus on those small times where
okay well maybe guys should adjust my
strategy to fit that little bit you want
to be again focused on the big picture
of okay well what generally works and
makes me the most money you can't
control the infinite possibilities that
the market has and that it's going to
throw at you and so now at this point
it's not looking that great since it's
pretty much just made this double top
right here and so at that point I'm
going to move my stop loss essentially
with idea that hey it's breaking this
uptrend and you know I I I'm going to
get out my you know I still want to
capture the profits that this move looks
like it's going to do and so you know it
has that double bottom here and I just
move my stop loss up to there and it
knocks me out and so make sure you get
that 90day road map in the description
below it's going to massively help you
follow the correct process to become a
consistently profitable Trader and also
make sure to watch this video right here
it's going to go through the five key
Concepts in drawing those support and
resistance levels that I use every time
honestly if I didn't have these key
Concepts to use use in the beginning I
wouldn't have found levels that would
easily reverse the market consistently